ernesto thank you for inviting me
thank you for gathering us
nuclear arms control is a global service
designed to protect the global commons
we can't protect the global commons
if there are mushroom clouds
there has not been a single mushroom
cloud
on a battlefield since 1945.
that's a remarkable achievement
really an unheralded achievement
nobody in 1945 who was concerned about
this problem
dared to hope that we could go
seven decades without the battlefield
use of a nuclear weapon
even more no major power
no regional power has even tested
a nuclear weapon underground
for two decades this too
is an extraordinary accomplishment
a hard-won accomplishment
because this treaty that bans all
nuclear tests
in all environments has been a goal
for really since the kennedy
administration
actually make that the eisenhower
administration
finally arrived 1996
it has yet to enter into force
but states
have felt obliged to honor it
states have either signed this treaty or
they have
expressed their intention
not to continue testing
at least for now amazing achievements
how did they happen
well some would argue that this record
unheralded record of accomplishment
happened because of deterrence
deterrence prevented weapons from being
used
on battlefields well there's
something to that argument but
deterrence is all about
threat and the greater the threat the
greater the deterrence or at least
so the practitioners practice
and threats aren't conducive
to nuclear arms control
threats deterrent threats haven't
reduced of a
single nuclear weapon not one
and yet global stockpiles of nuclear
weapons
mostly consisting of washington and
moscow's
stocks have been reduced by over 80
percent
so deterrence doesn't count for that
85 percent figure something else is
involved
so how did we go seven decades without
battlefield use
some people say well what about blind
dumb
luck maybe that's a reason
a contributing factor
and i don't discount it but there have
been
so many instances of close calls
mostly due to accidents breakdowns of
command and control
dozens of close calls can we attribute
non-use and non-mushroom
clouds to plain dumb luck
in every single instance i don't think
so
well then we can try divine intervention
maybe that's a contributing factor
i happen to believe it is a contributing
factor
but not everybody does especially the
rationalists who
pulled together this field of deterrence
based on rational actions
by rational actors
so what else have we got what else can
explain
this extraordinary circumstance
that we all benefit from well there is
this thing called nuclear arms control
and it has been
the product of decades of hard
diplomatic labor
and a building block approach if you
like the metaphor of construction
i prefer the metaphor of a safety net
a nuclear safety net
which has been woven assiduously
to stop nuclear testing
to reduce nuclear arms
to engage cooperatively
to reduce nuclear danger even
after the soviet union dissolved
with 39 000 weapons
the cooperative practices that
maintained
control over this
enormous nuclear stockpile
some of which was outside the confines
of the russian federation when the
soviet union dissolved
that was the result of hard work
and the antecedents allowed for success
after the soviet union dissolved
so this amazing
process of weaving a nuclear
safety net the thickest
strands of this net
were treaties treaties
and now these thick strands
are being cut
the nuclear safety net that we have
relied on
that has been so beneficial
and so unheralded
is being dismantled
the one of the major
preconditions for the steep reductions
that occurred
in these bloated superpower arsenals
was a treaty that banned
nationwide missile defenses
this treaty was negotiated during the
nixon
administration and it backstopped the
deep cuts
that came later but the treaty
has been cut
this thick strand of the nuclear safety
net
was cut during the george w bush
administration
as a result vladimir putin did some
cutting of his own
and he cut a treaty
strand thick strand
that said thou shalt not put more than
one warhead
on top of the missiles we worry the most
about
intercontinental ballistic missiles this
had been an objective
of arms controllers for decades
finally achieved by
george h.w bush
putin said look if you guys are going to
cut the abm treaty i'm going to
i'm not going to abide by this
obligation
and i'm going to go ahead and put more
than one missile excuse me
more than one warhead atop these
missiles and he's doing that
they're being deployed now
the treaty the thick strand in the
safety net
that foreclosed
the deployment of missiles
in europe or direct that could be
directed at
europe from certain distances
this intermediate nuclear forces treaty
signed by reagan and gorbachev
a treaty that did extreme violence
to nuclear orthodoxy
a treaty that broke the back of the
nuclear arms
race in 1987
cut this was a combined effort a joint
effort i would say
by putin and president trump and his
national security adviser john bolton
by the way i'm i'm throwing out
yale alumni here
but but snip
by snip by snip
this nuclear safety net
is being cut it now has very little
load-bearing capacity we don't know
how little until
we fall through it
and witness a mushroom cloud what do we
do about it
well in 1960 some very very
wise people came together
mostly along the banks of the charles
river
but also elsewhere and they ask
themselves two
fundamental questions what do we want
and what do we call it and
their answers were the same in both
cases
they devised this conceptualize this
practice of arms control
before they did this people were still
expressing fealty to general and
complete disarmament
but they really didn't mean it and they
had no way of getting there
arms control the practice of arms
control
was conceived at the right time
in the right place for a newly
elected president who were friends with
some of the conceptualizers
and brought them into his administration
where they began this amazing
construction project or weaving project
well
the practice of arms control
seems to have
sputtered and it may have run its course
i believe there's plenty of room for
another
arms reduction treaty with moscow
but sooner or later we're going to have
to conceive of something
to replace our old-fashioned concept of
arms control
2020 is the new 1960.
so we have two central questions
the same central questions
what do we want and what do we call
it
so i will end with where i started
arms control is a global service
designed to protect the global commons
whatever we call it in the future
to protect the global commons
we have to prevent mushroom clouds
no use
no use no battlefield use
no threats to use no
nuclear tests as a demonstration
of power and
evil intention to use
i think that's the heart of it but we
need to think about this some more
and we need a lot of help in thinking
this through
thank you
[Music]